Now let's walk through how shift might work together.
We can only shift if the next input token, the one we're currently looking at,
exactly matches c, the next thing we expect to see.
Now, you might have been tempted to have an i + 1 in here,
but remember that in Python lists and strings are indexed from zero,
so tokens bracket 0 is actually the first element of the input.
One of the first thing we have to do is check and see is cd empty or is it something?
Well, if cd is not empty, then we can take a look at its first element c,
and we'll just check to see how that compares to tokens i.
If they match exactly, then we can shift over that token.
We're going to return a new parsing state that still has x at the front,
but now instead of ab it should have abc, because we're shifting the red dot one.
Remember that c was the 0th element of cd.
We've shifted the red dot over one,
and now instead of cd on the right it's just going to have d on the right.
We want to peel off the first element of this list.
We can use Python's range selection to peel off all but the 0th element.
Let me just make my writing a bit more clear there.
This was really from j, and we are also from j.
If the stars did not align--either if cd was empty or it didn't match up the next token--
then we were supposed to return None.